bonjour avoir plusieurs maisons ou
plusieurs robes si on aime les robes
c'est une chance n'est ce pas avoir
plein de possibles c'est une chance
aussi avoir plusieurs langues
est ce que c'est une chance alors là on
commence à réfléchir
on se demande si parler plusieurs
langues ou apprendre plusieurs langues
c'est aussi simple que d'en apprendre
qu'une seule alors si c'est l'anglais ou
le japonais langue valoriser oui ça doit
être une chance je pense que la réponse
à ce moment là c'est oui en revanche si
je vous dis que je parle le soussou le
bambara l'arabe l'offre et le français
les langues d'origine de nos enfants de
migrants en france
alors ça se complique
est ce que le fait d'avoir une langue
maternelle ça serait pas une difficulté
pour bien parler le français
est ce que le plus important ce ne
serait pas de bien parler le français
est-ce que apprendre ou entendre parler
arabe à la maison ça serait pas un
obstacle qui vous empêche de d'apprendre
le bon français
est ce que pour bien parler le français
il faudrait pas mieux qu'on nous parle
français à la maison
plein de préjugés plein d'obstacles qui
montre que nous faisons une hiérarchie
entre les langues et que le statut de la
langue maternelle est mal connue et mal
reconnus en fait alors les recherches
on parlait tout à l'heure du monde de la
recherche les recherches sur le
bilinguisme sur le plurilinguisme sont
nombreuses et ancien 50 ans donc depuis
50 ans nous savons les chercheurs savent
que les bilingues et encore plus les
plurilingue
ceux qui parlent plusieurs langues qui
les ont a pris soin en même temps soit
successivement et bien que les bilingues
ont de meilleures capacités d'attention
que les autres ce les unilingues ceux
qui ne parle qu'une seule langue
les chercheurs ont montré également que
si nous sommes bilingues
nous avons une plus grande capacité à
nous adapter aux univers aux règles aux
questions ils ont montré aussi que les
bilingues avait des capacités qu'on dit
métalinguistique beaucoup plus
importante c'est à dire qu'ils sont
capables de faire très tôt tout petits
ils sont capables de faire la différence
entre la chose et le mot ce que en
général nous n'apprenons que beaucoup
plus tard
autour des années lycée et la
philosophie donc finalement la recherche
si je la résume internationale sur le
bilinguisme c'est c'est très aisé
d'apprendre plusieurs langues pour des
enfants ce n'est que du bonheur que du
savoir que de la chance bien
pourtant il ya des préjugés absolument
incroyable sur cette question et j'ai la
chance je sus pédopsychiatre et je
dirige la maison de solenn à paris je
rencontre donc tous les jours des
enfants de migrants et leurs familles et
ces familles alors que ce soit des
enfants de migrants des enfants de
couples mixtes mais aussi des enfants de
l'adoption internationale
toutes ces situations où on traverse
plusieurs langues où les enfants
traversent plusieurs langues
eh bien ces familles disent combien
c'est difficile
cette idée d'avoir plusieurs langues
les préjugés les fausses idées les
conseils qui sont totalement étonnant
comme un enfant il faut lui parler
successivement mais pas en même temps
plusieurs langues c'est à dire il faut
toujours que ce soit la même personne
qui parle la langue pas et la même
personne qui parlerait la langue mais
parce que sinon ils vont confondre ils
vont mal parler les deux langues
plein de préjugés qui n'ont aucun sou va
cement scientifique mais qui qui qui
sont des sortes de certitudes que nous
projetons sur les enfants qui ont
plusieurs langues
alors moi j'ai eu la chance parce que
j'ai une gueule j'ai appris à parler en
espagnol
je suis né en espagne j'ai ensuite
grandi dans un village d'un petit
village ardennais et j'ai donc appris le
français à 6 ans lorsque je suis rentrée
à l'école et en quelques semaines comme
tous les enfants de cet âge j'ai appris
le français
mais j'ai eu la chance qu une rencontre
incroyable d'avoir une institutrice qui
comprenait intuitivement la singularité
et la particularité des enfants
bilingues et qui le valorise et je vous
raconte une toute petite histoire
un jour je dis à ma
petit camarade je lui dit s'il te plaît
passe moi ma bouffe andes
j'avais inventé un mot à partir de je ne
savais pas dire cache nez et donc à
partir du mot espagnol bout fans des
jeux les franciser je les transforme et
dans un joli mot que je propose
aujourd'hui à plomb plutôt que cachent
les bouffons l'institutrice qui passait
par là en temps ma création de mots et
dit à ma petite camarade tu sais
marie-rose lé poète et pourquoi j'étais
devenu poète un peu étonnés comme à moi
pourquoi j'étais devenu poète parce que
j'avais inventé un mot et que c'est une
licence poétique
les poètes peuvent inventer des mots le
lendemain nous avons ocp tous toute la
classe un cours sur la licence poétique
c'est à dire que non seulement elle
n'avait elle avait considéré que je
n'avais pas fait une erreur que c'était
une sorte de de bricolage entre mes
langues
donc non seulement ce n'était pas une
erreur mais c'était une chance puisque
ça permettait à tous les enfants de se
familiariser avec cette idée du
bilinguisme et puis 2 pourquoi en créer
des mots et quand est-ce qu'on peut
créer des mots alors cette institutrice
elle avait intuitivement compris qu
effectivement les enfants bilingues
peuvent avoir des singularités mais que
ces singularités sont bonnes pour tous
et elle avait aussi compris l'importance
de valoriser ma langue maternelle
alors cette question du statut de la
langue maternelle
aujourd'hui on sait combien cette langue
maternelle est si important parce que
c'est celle qui nous permet d'être des
personnes qui parlent et qui aime parler
sans doute suis-je devant vous ici
aujourd'hui avec autant de plaisir
ce que j'ai appris à parler et que dans
ma langue maternelle et que ce processus
a été valorisé aussi pour la suite pour
mon rapport au savoir alors si si c'est
comme ça
si la langue maternelle est si
importante si le bilinguisme c'est qu
une richesse pour les enfants pourquoi
c'est si difficile
pourquoi par exemple en france seulement
10% des enfants de migrants sont
bilingues seulement 10%
c'est très peu en angleterre en suède
dans les pays du nord de la france
soixante pour cent soixante pour cent
des enfants de migrants sont bilingues
même avec l'anglais qui est pourtant
cette langue si si importante
hégémonique 1 puisque l'anglais on peut
ça aide à traverser les pays
soixante pour cent des enfants de
migrants en angleterre sont bilingues et
il faut constater également que dans ces
pays
nous ne nous n'assistons pas à ce que
l'on peut voir parfois dans notre pays
des adolescents issus de la migration
qui au cours d'un match de football vont
siffler la france et vont avoir un
sentiment de de déloyauté ils vont
siffler la france des choses qu'on
n'entend pas dans d'autres pays
pourquoi parce que cette manière de
valoriser les différentes appartenances
des enfants les différentes langues des
enfants ça aide à faire nous ça aide à
s'inscrire dans un groupe mais en france
nous ne transmettons pas et nous ne
favorisons pas la transmission des
langues
pourquoi mais c'est parce qu'on a peur
du communautarisme c'est d'ailleurs un
mot qui est un mot très considéré comme
très négatif la notion
deux communautés pourtant ce qui fait
communautarisme ce qui va favoriser le
communautarisme c'est le rejet la peur
le manque de fraternité
le manque de solidarité ce départ la
reconnaissance ce n'est pas l'inclusion
dans le groupe
donc cette question est très important à
l'école à l'école toutes les études
internationales et les étude française
montre que les enfants de migrants qui
réussissent le mieux à l'école ils sont
soit bilingue soit ils ont une
représentation positive dans leur langue
maternelle
ils en sont fiers il trouve que c'est
bien d'avoir cette langue à la maison et
de pouvoir le partager avec d'autres
donc il découle de cela un certain
nombre de choses très pratique si un
enfant un peu de mal à parler lorsqu'il
rentre à l'école en français alors au
lieu de lui dire madame parlez-lui
français à la maison il faut lui dire
madame vous qui est la maman
parlez-lui votre langue maternelle
montrez lui délivra comptait lui des
histoires pour qu'il retrouve une
sécurité dans la langue et qu'il n'est
plus peur du français plus grand plus
grand au cp lorsque on apprend le
français lire et à écrire en français
il ya plein de technique on les connaît
mais on les utilise très peu qui
permettent de faire des liens entre les
langues
il ya des techniques le par exemple
travaillé sur le conte bilingue dans les
deux langues ou faire des liens entre
les langues ou utiliser les enfants
comme des experts ou même leurs parents
laisser les parents et leur langue
rentrée à l'école
or en général nous ne connaissons pas
les langues maternelles de nos enfants
adolescents la langue maternelle c'est
ce qui permet de choisir ce que l'on va
vouloir faire par exemple de la poésie
persane de la calligraphie arabe ou du
flamenco espagnol je choisis si je ne
peux pas choisir parce que je n'ai pas
de langue maternelle à ma disposition
alors si je me sent victime si je n'ai
pas la fierté de mon monde de mon
univers de mes parents je vais être à la
merci des des choses beaucoup plus
simple et beaucoup plus violente qui
sont par exemple les dérives religieuses
transnationales ou ces groupes qui vont
donc me donner l'illusion que je suis
bon que je ce jeu sert à quelque chose
et que je leur ressemble
c'est donc là un danger une tentation
très grave et un peu tragique et il est
important que nous puissions donner à
ces adolescents d'autres possibilités
que ces tentations violente et
meurtrière
ainsi si on résume cette question des
langues maternelles reconnaître les
langues maternelles des enfants les
aimer les valoriser c'est bon pour les
enfants
ça les aide à être performant à être
heureux et à être tranquille avec leur
histoire mais aussi c'est bon pour nous
parce que ça crée un lien social où il
ya de la place pour tous
on laisse personne sur le chemin et où
toutes les histoires sont métissés
transformé pour faire pour faire un
groupe
et comme le dit mona ozouf cette grande
historienne chez qui on parlait le
breton reconnaître ces langues
maternelles reconnaître cette diversité
c'est d'une certaine façon donner la
possibilité à chacun de dire nous c'est
ce que je leur souhaite c'est ce que je
nous souhaite et je vous remercie
infiniment en français
à force et contient toutes les langues